well the announcement today is all about
headlines it's not about public health
the prime minister has said that he's
going to be driven by the data
not by dates he doesn't have the data
yet he won't have the data until later
this week so he's not in a position
to take a decision until next monday so
you have to wonder what today's
announcement is all about and i think
it's about party management
rather than the public interest we all
want the restrictions
to be lifted and we're gonna have to
find a way of living with the
virus but that can't just be a sound
bite
we need a proper plan and to
throw off all protections at the same
time
when the infection rate is still going
up is reckless we need a
balanced approach we need to keep key
protections in place
including masks including ventilation
and crucially something we've been
asking for throughout the pandemic
proper payments to those that need to
self-isolate
so which legal restrictions do you want
to keep after the 19th of july
lifting all protections in one go
when the infection rate is going up is
reckless
a balanced approach a proper plan would
say keep key protections
one of them would be masks in enclosed
places and on public transport that's a
common sense
position more ventilation that's
happening in other countries
is absolutely essential and proper
payments for those that need to
self-isolate that is what a balanced
approach would take but simply throwing
off all protections when infection rate
is going up it is reckless
so unions are saying that uh to lift the
compulsory marks wearing
would be an act of gross negligence do
you agree with that you would keep
legal restrictions on wearing masks i
think common sense has to play a part
here
the public know the infection rate is
going up
and they're bound to pinch themselves
and say why on earth then are you
throwing off all protections at the same
time
of course we want to open up of course
we want to end
these restrictions we want our
businesses to be up fully running we all
want
that but to throw off all protections at
the same time
is reckless the prime minister says if
not now
when it is better to do it now than in
the autumn in the winter when as he says
the virus has an edge
why isn't he right on that well he says
if not now then when he hasn't seen the
data yet
he's not getting the data until the end
of the week if you can believe it
he's making this announcement now he
hasn't got the data
he's describing what he wants to happen
not what he can say is going to happen
because he hasn't seen
the data that is no way to make it a
decision as important as this and
common sense dictates that you take a
balanced approach here
and don't throw off all protections at
the same time if you don't last one but
if you don't mind me just
saying you know you're saying he hasn't
seen the data and therefore can't make
this decision
but then neither of you but you're
saying it's still too early to lift all
these restrictions so
so when what would you need to see in
the data to lift all the restrictions
well we all need to see the data
but nobody but nobody is predicting that
the data is going to say other one
the infection rate is going to continue
to go up the prime minister's as good as
admitted that we'll have to see by how
much
but the idea that as the infection rate
goes up you throw off all protections at
the same time
i'm afraid it's reckless so what would
labour need to see
to get to the point of removing all
restrictions we need to see the data
and then we need a plan to live with the
virus i think a sensible plan would say
keep masks in enclosed places and on
public transport
at least until we're past the peak and
the numbers are coming down that would
be a common sense
position put more into ventilation of
buildings
and fix the problem that's been there
throughout which is to make proper
proper payments to those that need to
self-isolate